il comparto economico che più
contribuisce al pil italiano è il re tel
ma sapete qual è il comparto il secondo
che contribuisce al pil dell'italia
questo è il turismo con il 13 e 4 per
cento di contribuzione
ed è anche il comparto che nell'ultimo
anno è cresciuto di più rispetto a tutti
con il 3 e 4 per cento di crescita sul
sulla bretella e questo dato ancora più
interessante se pensate che l'italia è
cresciuta solo dello 0 9 per cento
l'anno scorso quindi il turismo è un
comparto che cresce nonostante la crisi
nonostante il rallentamento globale
dell'economia il turismo dal lavoro in
italia
al 15 per cento del della popolazione
occupata ora il iniziato a lavorare nel
turismo
tredici anni fa e quando mi rivolgevo ai
colleghi ai miei alle persone che già
avevano un'attività nel settore
extralberghiero la maggioranza di loro
condivideva con me problemi mi diceva
che non c'erano più i tempi di una volta
che non si guadagnava come una volta
davano la colpa di questo allo stato
alle istituzioni alle leggi troppo
ingarbugliate del nostro settore devono
la colpa all'esterno cioè lasciavano la
responsabilità della loro attività in un
raggio di azione dove loro non avevano
potere
io da subito detto no a questo status
quo ho preso in mano quella che era la
mia piccola attività ho preso la
responsabilità di questa attività e ho
cercato di capire
ho studiato come in italia si potesse
vivere di turismo e nel fare questo ho
scoperto che la nostra nazione è una
delle nazioni con più attrazioni al
mondo per i viaggiatori
abbiamo 55 siti unesco ed altri 41 sono
in lista di attesa per diventare
patrimonio dell'umanità che tutto il
mondo vuole venire a vedere
solo per farvi un paragone la francia
che il paese più visitato al mondo nel
solo 41 e poi abbiamo laghi montagna
abbiamo borghi con una cultura e delle
bellezze incredibili
abbiamo palazzi chiese giardini musei e
tutto questo caratteristica italiana è
vicino cioè non serve spostarsi tanto
per godere di diversità ma di una
potenza dal punto di vista culturale
enorme
il turista in italia impazzisce perché
si sposta di 10 km e cambia la lingua il
dialetto cambia la cultura
cambia la ventura cambiano le tradizioni
culinarie abbiamo un enogastronomia che
tutto il mondo ci invidia
ora giusto per darvi una proporzione le
canarie sono infinitamente più piccola
ma fanno otto volte il numero di arrivi
della sardegna
quindi c'è probabilmente qualcosa che
non va le persone che vengono in italia
mediamente non tornano a roma i due
terzi delle persone che visitano la
città eterna decidono di non tornare
e questo probabilmente perché l'italia
negli ultimi anni non ha manifestato
energia buone vibrazioni felicità
serenità che poi è quello che cerca il
turista quando quando viaggio
il viaggio è un momento particolare
tutti noi quando viaggiamo sappiamo che
andiamo incontro a l'ignoto ma decidiamo
di farlo per una specifica ragione
perché abbiamo bisogno di lasciare le
abitudini di abbandonare per un attimo
la nostra routine
e di aprirci a qualcosa di nuovo aprire
il nostro cuore è un'esperienza a un
territorio farci contaminare vivere
delle emozioni nuove che possano
arricchirsi e farci tornare a casa più
ricchi di come siamo partiti il viaggio
e avventura ma è anche ricerca di una
serenità e quindi se io decido la
destinazione banalmente dove voglio
andare voglio andare una destinazione
felice è vero no non vado in una
destinazione di guerra ho paura voglio
andare a stare bene
ecco che l'italia negli ultimi anni non
ha manifestato questa felicità questa
energia sono cresciute destinazioni come
la croazia
l'albania il brasile dove c'è vibrazione
c'è voglia di crescere voglia di fare
l'italia no eppure ragazzi l'italia è
nei sondaggi degli ultimi anni sempre al
primo posto al mondo come destinazione
dove le persone vogliono andare
quindi se si chiede dove vuoi andare in
vacanza la risposta nel mondo è l'italia
poi andiamo a vedere la classifica dei
paesi visitati e siamo solo al quinto
posto dopo francia cina spagna e stati
uniti d'america
quindi vedete c'è qualcosa che non va
probabilmente abbiamo bisogno di
ritornare anche noi a essere felici
essere sereni perché attraverso questa
serenità
possiamo accogliere i turisti in maniera
corretta e come si fa ad essere più
sereni più felici sicuramente abbiamo la
necessità di essere consapevoli del
nostro territorio
abbiamo necessità di capire da dove
veniamo capire dove dove stiamo capire
cosa ci circonda conoscere le bellezze
del nostro territorio perché questo è
quello che ha fatto grande l'italia
questo è quello di cui noi possiamo
andare orgogliosi noi viviamo in una
società dove pensiamo che dobbiamo avere
altre cose per stare bene in realtà
possiamo stare bene
già con quello che abbiamo
dobbiamo passare più sul lato
dell'essere che sul lato della vera è
molto complesso perché i media ci dicono
sempre che bisogna avere qualcos'altro
per stare bene siamo cresciuti con
questa cultura
in realtà il territorio può offrire
tanto e consapevolizzare quello che
abbiamo intorno
ci può far stare meglio quello che dico
sempre che prima di accogliere i turisti
dobbiamo accogliere noi stessi le nostre
esigenze
perché solo così possiamo trovare un
equilibrio stare meglio noi e aprire le
porte della nostra nazione a tutto il
mondo che a quel punto si viene a
visitare i territori ma viene a
conoscere anche attraverso i nostri
occhi attraverso il nostro cuore quella
che è l'essenza della cultura
dell'italianità
c'è un settore dove io mi impegno da
tanti anni che il settore
extralberghiero che può essere una
chiave per rilanciare l'economia del
nostro paese sta già accadendo
il settore alberghiero è composto da
case vacanza da bed and breakfast da
affitti turistici e da tutto quello per
intenderci che non è albergo il settore
extralberghiero per giusto per darvi
qualche numero
negli ultimi anni è cresciuto talmente
tanto da rappresentare oggi il 55 per
cento dei posti letto presenti sul
nostro paese e questo vuol dire che è
più di una persona su due soggiorna fa
la sua vacanza all'interno di una
struttura extralberghiera negli ultimi
anni il settore è cresciuto del a doppia
cifra ogni anno e considerate che su
tredici città ti ho analizzato
recentemente di cui ho guardato i numeri
la crescita nell'ultimo trimestre di
questo settore è stata del 13 per cento
solo negli ultimi tre mesi quindi capite
bene come stiamo parlando di una realtà
che coinvolge
veramente un sacco di persone sono
attualmente oltre 400 mila le aziende e
le persone coinvolte
all'interno di questo movimento nel
nostro paese perché il successo del
settore extralberghiero cosa di diverso
in un comparto turismo per cui può
essere il traino di questa ripresa
economica della nostra nazione ci sono
persone che danno ospitalità ad altre
persone in un momento dove si è alla
ricerca dell'essenza delle cose vere
dell'autenticità e bellissimo per un
turista sapere che dall'altra parte del
computer e dall'altra parte del mondo
c'è una persona reale in carne ed ossa
che si sta prendendo cura di allestire
l'immobile perché aspetta il suo arrivo
questo fa sì che il turista abbia sempre
più confidenza e sono le recensioni che
confermano che danno valore ancora di
più a questa fiducia perché sono se
guardate le recensioni spesso di
alberghi di catene sono hanno un
punteggio più basso di un bed and
breakfast gestita in maniera amatoriale
perché turista ama e cerca l'autenticità
una struttura extralberghiera è la porta
di accesso a un territorio attraverso la
conoscenza del gestore di questa
struttura
il viaggiatore può scoprire l'essenza
del territorio quei ristoranti dove
andare a mangiare i luoghi da visitare
le cose da scoprire le esperienze da
vivere all'interno di quel territorio
stesso
e poi c'è un'altra caratteristica che
porta questo settore ad essere veramente
un traino per l'economia italiana e sono
questi numeri
oggi in italia per cultura abbiamo
tantissimi immobili come seconda terza
quarta casa
e se fino a qualche anno fa venivano
utilizzati per la villeggiatura
oggi date le abitudini e anche la
condizione economica cambiata con
l'arrivo dell'euro
le persone fanno vacanze sempre più
ristretta quindi esistono sul mercato
oggi in italia 3 milioni di immobili
sfitti
oltre a 130.000 residenze d'epoca e
dimore storiche che non sono utilizzata
è un patrimonio immenso che spesso
incide tanto nella vita di una comunità
questi immobili la maggior parte delle
volte si trovano in luoghi imposti di
una bellezza disarmante come i centri
storici dei nostri borghi come le
montagne come piccoli paesini dove
finora magari non si è visto nemmeno un
turista
ecco dietro un immobile ragazzi
abbandonato c'è sempre sempre una ferita
nella persona che quell'immobile lo
possiede c'è un proprietario con
difficoltà economica c'è un trauma a
volte sono fratelli che non si parlano a
seguito di un eredità a volte sono ci
sono stati dei lutti sono molti nonni
figli abitano i nipoti troppo lontano
per prendersi cura
ci sono nella migliore delle ipotesi
delle problematiche economiche ad ogni
modo il trauma e il disagio di un
immobile abbandonato è un disagio del
singolo ma è un disagio per tutta la
comunità che attraverso la vista di
quell'immobile percepisce l'incuria e il
problema che è che c'è dietro anche se
non lo conosciamo esattamente lo
percepiamo quindi il settore
extralberghiero cosa può fare beh può
prendersi cura di questi immobili e
offrirli ai turisti ai viaggiatori
secondo l'organizzazione mondiale del
turismo il turista kia è quello che
abbiamo in mente con la valigia sa tre
giorni e va via
ma in generale il turista è definito
colui che lascia la sua casa di
residenza per trascorrere un periodo
inferiore a 12 mesi presso un'altra
un'altra abitazione
ecco questo è il turista di cui vi sto
parlando dovete sapere che esistono
turisti molto diversi da quelli che ci
immaginiamo ad esempio il nome di
digitali che lavorano con il computer
possono praticamente esplorare un
territorio vivendolo anche per alcuni
mesi e il trend di viaggiare in questo
modo di abbandonare la propria casa per
vivere esperienze autentiche all'interno
di borghi in altre nazioni è talmente
forte che si prevede che nei prossimi
cinque anni nel mondo saranno 5 milioni
le persone a muoversi in questo modo
quindi capita che il settore
extralberghiero può essere una risorsa
importantissima importantissima perché
possiamo offrire quindi accogliere
questa persona importante per chi
gestisce questa attività perché genera
economia per se stesso
il settore genera economia per i
proprietari ma anche per i gestori ma
anche per colui che cerca semplicemente
un reddito integrativo e attraverso il
settore extralberghiero può guadagnare
quelle 3 400 euro che gli permettono di
ottenere di più dalla sua vita poi ci
sono tutte
tutto un indotto che gira intorno al
settore che le persone che offrono i
servizi le persone che muratori
idraulici ingegneri tutte persone che
lavorano e offrono appunto il loro
apporto e il settore extra alberghiero
da lavoro sul territorio
ora il problema ragazze che a questo
nostro territorio come noi lo stiamo
vivendo e conoscendo oggi gli stranieri
lo conoscono meglio di noi spesso e
tante persone vengono in italia
acquistano immobili avviano attività
anche nel settore extralberghiero
ora la domanda che mi faccio è questa
vogliamo davvero dare
responsabilità della rinascita economica
dell'italia all'estero oppure vogliamo
prendere noi la responsabilità del
nostro futuro
allora vi voglio raccontare una storia
che è quella di donato che ha acquistato
un terreno per coltivare e ha creato un
piccolo ristorante pietra dopo pietra
quel terreno è diventato ha dato origine
a una masseria all'inizio era una stanza
poi è cresciuta e ha dato lavoro a 25
persone
queste se voi andate in questa masseria
il rispetto di donato per il 3 del
territorio la tradizione ha portato una
sensazione unica
le pareti parlano della storia delle
persone che hanno vissuto in quella
masseria gioia e dolori parti pianti
economie che hanno girato in quella
masseria e i turisti accorrono in massa
donato all'interno della sua esperienza
che è durata per tanti decenni del suo
amore della passione per il territorio e
racchiude l'essenza di quello che vi sto
dicendo quindi conoscenza del territorio
rispetto felicità serenità con quello
che si sta facendo e economia attraverso
il suo esempio tanti giovani sono
rimasti nel paese e hanno continuato a
generare economia l'azione che invito a
fare è essere consapevoli e il vostro
territorio godere di quello che abbiamo
perché godere di quello che abbiamo
perché il beneficio che ne avremo sarà
un futuro migliore per l'italia un
futuro migliore per i nostri figli che
potranno essere felici di avere una
prospettiva per il futuro e magari
guardarsi indietro ed essere orgogliosi
del lavoro che oggi noi stiamo facendo
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]